what year was this like freshman year
2007 freshman year
so i come in from winter break i open
the door and you know bob's there and
i'm just like
let's lock the beds like i don't think i
said hello first i think i like walked
in the door and was like you want a loft
you want to put the beds in on on top
bunk them you want to bunk the beds well
we'd have so much more room for
activities that way i know god that
movie hadn't even come out
that's exactly what we were doing we
wanted room for activities like we need
more space for when people come over
when we have all these parties obviously
we're cool guys you guys throw a lot of
parties after this yeah sure yeah yeah
yeah
we definitely threw at least one
we did throw one
great
i can't hear how worth it this was so
mark enters and so our current setup we
basically split the room in half right
but it's not that big of a room like if
we were standing shoulder to shoulder
we'd probably take up the whole width of
the center of that room yeah so if you
bunk one bed on top of the other you get
like a quarter of the room but the way
the beds are supposed to go together
when you bunk them you're supposed to
one
lower the height of the bed that goes on
top because when they're on the floor
the bed is like all the way up on the
highest setting it can go right so you
can put stuff under it okay but if you
leave it like that and then put it on
top of another bed there's like maybe a
foot between the bed
and the ceiling yeah really legitimately
so you're supposed to change that
but that required like
tools or
i don't know knowledge
we didn't know how to do that so we
didn't do that of course not so we're
looking at this and we're like yeah i
don't think we need i don't we can't
adjust your bet i think and mark is like
that's fine that's fine i'll sleep up
high
good air up high it'll be fine
like we get past that hurdle the other
thing about this is other than the fact
that you're supposed to one ask for
permission and two ask for help from
adults there's supposed to be a thick
metal pin in each of the four legs that
lock it in place so that they can't slip
off that seems crucially important
and then we're looking and we're like
all right metal pins metal pins we don't
have metal pins and i don't know i think
it was you mark i got i gotta give you
credit words too we're sitting there
like brainstorming and mark like goes
into his wardrobe and turns back to me
with a pair of scissors
and a plastic clothes hanger
and it's like if we just snip this
straight part of this clothes hanger
it's like metal pins
it was the perfect size it fit perfectly
it was the right diameter it has i'm
pretty sure plastic clothes hangers you
can snap with your bare hands have the
same tensile and shear strength as metal
pins so like yeah he looks at me and of
course he holds up the scissors and the
thing and i look at him and i'm like
perfect
how big do you think they need to be
let's do this
no hesitation at all oh
and my favorite part of this whole thing
we eyeball them to the same ish length
set them all in we hoist the bed up
really precariously
set it on the pins one of the four pins
was like half an inch longer than the
other ones
and it was half an inch too long
so the bed the weight of that corner of
mark's bunked bed which is now like 10
feet off the ground the weight of that
bed is sitting on the plastic clothes
hanger and we sort of like i don't
remember the conversation but we looked
at it for maybe a second like 10 seconds
total
and then mark was just like ah [ __ ] it
of course
and just climbed up and so for the
entire rest of that school year yeah
mark's bunk bed one quarter of the legs
was supported by like a quarter inch
thick piece of plastic you should be
[ __ ] dead
[Music]